um all right hello everyone and welcome
to this review discussion thing that
I've been doing with friends about each
episode of The Last of Us I'm Alana
that's Eddie who are you Eddie
who am I yes
you know how did we do do we have the
whole stream
I got a lot of things to say about me
uh how about you Jacob Christensen that
whoa biblical yeah uh
yeah uh hey also does YouTube oh yeah
sorry the yoga ball game or something
might call them I do YouTube
I hate it so much
um we are here to talk about episode
four of the last of us but I wanted to
ask you guys first how you feeling about
the show so far Eddie what are you what
are your thoughts thus far on HBO is the
last of us have absolutely loved every
episode I think
um I think
even speaking a little of the changes to
the show have only made the story in
this format better
um I just I really like it a lot I'm I'm
very Pro this show hot take yeah yeah
very far from the general consensus
thing how about you Jakey I I mirror
everything Eddie said I I knew that I
was probably gonna like it and that it
was going to be good but like I really
like it and I feel like every episode
it's I'm like
having played the original game like
five six times like knowing at the like
the back of my hand and like you know
the parts where the dialogue is directly
out of the game I'm pretty sure I've
annoyed Billy like directly like last
night when she's like bye-bye dude and
like throws a thing like that whole
scene I was saying like I was an
annoying ass Like a Star Wars fan like
literally
no I I agree with Eddie I think every
change they've made has been for the
better and uh I like for the TV format
which yeah no I think episode three was
especially amazing and I think the last
night's episode was like amazing for
different reasons like I felt like sick
to my stomach and because we could talk
about spoilers right like yeah go all
out the scene where they uh the first
like combat you know with the truck
Ambush and back with props to the guy
the Brian guy that died that like I said
out loud that dude is acting this little
HBO hot out right here I really did feel
like sick when I was watching it I'm
just like I don't know my legs don't
move like well it was like the riding
was so good and just real and then he's
just saying like Mom and it's like oh
man if they really wanted to convey the
violence like holy [__] and I think
that's really okay
um I was just gonna say I think it's
also a better and more clear
representation of who Joel is the fact
that that's shifted from that moment in
the game not only it being like a little
bit earlier but him kind of like the way
he has to kind of step in and handle it
there
um and I also love uh the way he reacts
to it later versus the game
um because in the game a little bit
sometimes I was like Joel you just got
your life saved man don't you you know
what I mean like because he's from what
I remember like pretty because they've
combined the they like combined the
scene where he's getting drowned with
yeah because that happened later yeah
yeah in the hotel yeah but also the
first time because I'm currently
replaying through the game but I haven't
played it in a while so I remember
pretty much every feat but didn't the
um like she doesn't kill this guy
whereas in the show that conversation
sorry in the game that conversation
happens after she's actually killed
someone right yeah like she kills him
and he dies yeah yeah that's pretty much
like the same scenario up until the
point that the guy lives from the
balloon at least in that moment
um and then yeah Joel is very like
against it happening but like reasonably
in the world it's like I'm not it wasn't
uh out of character for Joel to act that
way in the game but I do like this
version of him kind of apologizing for
it and knowing that Ellie shouldn't have
had to do it yeah um I just liked it it
was a nice change yeah I think but like
to your point about it being super
harrowing Jakey is that's a thing that I
think is really important in the show
that they've done really well is make
sure that when these things happen we're
really confronted by it whereas when it
happens in a game you're like oh I'm
gonna shoot more people and the balance
of where the violence is and how the
violence plays out I feel like is like
expertly done so that TV audiences
aren't like oh this is [__] up like
they're like wow this is sad yeah yeah
uh I was talking with Billy because we
we've been watching it every week and um
the I couldn't help but notice in a good
way but when they like the the chatter
that the I guess enemies did in the show
felt so much like part two of like Brian
they killed Richard yeah exactly no bear
like specifically even to the names they
used it felt in a good way like part two
but like anyone that's familiar with my
[__] knows I have issues with part two
as like a game but like as a story it
makes me so excited to see how they
handle adapting part two because I feel
like I feel like I would have a much
more uh
I don't know we could talk a billion
hours about part two like I have so many
feelings about it but just to say I've
been so impressed with what they've done
and like their writing and how they're
slightly changing stuff like
yeah and I I do suspect that
one of the things that I um it's not
like a criticism but it's a thing that I
haven't liked as a thing that I also
understand is that I feel like Ellie in
the show is a lot harsher than she is in
the game and she is she's way hot show
in the game they bond a lot faster so in
this episode I was really really happy
to see them like finally actually like
smile at each other and that Bond come
through starting with the magazine scene
which like you said is so cool to see
like be almost exactly one to one
because the writing was perfect to begin
with why change it and then I think he
laughs at the pun stuff a little bit
earlier in the game but like leaving
that to the very end was a thing that I
was like oh man like this is so nice to
finally see it's gonna break my heart
like yeah I can't wait to see other
people react it's his when me and Billy
run a walk today I was talking about how
like his specific acting of like just
barely cracking a smile when she first
drops the puns and then the ending when
they like build up him fully laughing
it's just so nice to finally get that
and I think probably part of why they've
made Ellie a little bit tougher in the
Show versus in the game outside of it
being a different medium and said this
million times but like you know when
you're in the game you need to have a
lot of empathy for her because you're
the one escorting her like you feel like
you are doing it whereas we're watching
it happen is because I feel like that'll
lead in to part two or season two a
little bit better for the TV audience as
well I think so too I think like me and
Eddie were talking about that of the uh
the scene in I think it's episode two or
the beginning It's Beginning a three
with the night beginning of three when
she's like just staring at the zombie
and like Cuts him open and yeah what did
you think about me and Eddie both had
like I and I I agreed with him after he
told me but I feel like we had different
interpretations of it but I think Eddie
if you don't mind kind of repeating what
you were saying your kind of take on it
I didn't feel like it was fully driven
by this reason but it felt a little bit
because of what we know of um Ellie's
like very recent past where we're
picking up with her in the game that it
almost felt like a little sadistic of of
like uh an interest but then the kit the
kill of it didn't seem like Mercy it
seemed like a [__] you you know and I
think it's because you know she's just
dealing with somebody you know she
really cared about being killed by one
of them
um so yeah that's what I got but Jakey
you had a it was uh different it was
like curiosity for you right yeah it was
like same but different like I I get
that too that it was like maybe a a
little bit sadistic or that like ooh
like I'm I don't know if I would say
she's like deriving pleasure out of it
but like maybe a little bit but when I
watched it I thought that yeah it was uh
it was like a curiosity thing of like oh
I have this thing living in me in some
capacity even though I'm immune to it so
I want to cut this thing open to see it
because it's like cutting myself open
almost and seeing yeah I don't know you
know just but I as a credit to the show
I like that even that one scene you can
look at it from these different
perspectives that like totally wrong
actually do you want me to tell you what
the truth is the truth is with that
because uh Troy told me because I asked
him do you want me to tell you yeah yeah
when I was like why did she do that
because like you said it's open to
interpretation which I think is cool
Troy said
um because she's violent and that that's
supposed to be a big core of Ellie is
violent so I think this did sadistic
take is correct he'd also mention that
like when Jill kills the guy in the end
of episode one I don't even know anymore
it's been so many hours but she watches
him freaking yeah that like she was
enjoying that um so it is definitely a
more aggressive version of Ellie and
like I said I I was really hoping to see
more of that relationship because we
were at a point with the previous
episodes where I didn't like really like
seeing the two of them together that
much because I like they didn't have a
bond or seem to care about each other
and that finally came through and like I
did expect this to happen but I feel
like it was so well paced like the
timing of that finally happening of like
them getting over grief of them seeing
people who managed to survive and were
in love throughout all of the
circumstances and then they leave
um on this journey and she's in a car
for the first time which I really still
love the line of like she's like it's
like a spaceship like because you would
think that and also spaceship yeah
that's true made that connection I was
also gonna mention I don't wanna
especially when I don't know how the
production of the show was I always I'm
careful to credit like one person for an
input thing when I don't know fully but
I think especially that joke moment we
were talking about
um seems to be like a perfect kind of
example of CR what seems to be Craig's
input on the show of somebody who really
really cares and knows the first story
but is also like Show run a different
project and wants to like put his own
little spin on it because like the pun
moment like the one of those moments in
the game is already like very endearing
and great and we know worked because we
all love the story but it's like so
like like such an intimate human fun
moment in the show that we saw yesterday
when they finally break and laugh
together and it seems like a much more
personal connection like that you could
show on TV than you could feel in a game
of like two people laughing together you
know
yeah and that scene being what it was of
like him laying down
the glass as well to try to protect her
did the the because again you've both
played the game more recently than I
have you know she mentions that he's
deaf in one ear or like has Wes I didn't
remember that I didn't think that
happened in the game either and it makes
sense that he's like you know yeah but I
was also wondering if maybe that was in
part
that's where Sarah got shot
I had that thought when we were watching
the show too that it was like that he I
mean he says like maybe it's more from
shooting but when he says getting shot
at I was like oh that yeah but I don't
remember in the first episode if he had
like a like uh you know and uh
this is such a dumb stretch there's an
episode of Breaking Bad where Mike is in
the back of the truck and he gets shot
in his ear and it's like hanging up I
don't remember seeing that on Joel in
like the first episode I don't know I
know but that's that's what my head went
to which is like the whole thing
especially now that you've seen himself
in a little bit which he was definitely
playing a more
muted version of Joel I'd seen that
criticism it was one that I didn't agree
with but opinions yay was that um Joel
doesn't talk enough and he's very quiet
in the show and to me in the show that
comes across more than it did in the
game as a man who is uncomfortable
basically caring for a child again after
having spent so many years recovering
from what happened with Sarah that's the
way I'm taking it at least is he's like
I don't want to care about you the way
open up totally and just like have this
happen again I need to treat you as
cargo and he's definitely still trying
to and it's interesting that she's not
more resistant to it but that's that's
how it feels in the show in the game I
felt like he was a lot nicer earlier a
lot earlier as well but I'm not sure if
that's just yeah I I think so too that I
think it was oh I was just gonna say I
feel like it's all uh just this whole
first section I was telling Eddie before
I really like this episode of how in the
show it's like we're at bills we do all
that which you know in the show is
shorter because the bill Phillips that
focused on something that I liked a lot
more and I think that was way better but
um
uh in the game it's like they get the
truck and then they get ambushed in
Pittsburgh and it's like the one scene
in the car where she's like bye-bye dude
and throws the magazine with the [__] on
it and
um and then they get ambushed but I
really like it just also just felt more
real but to show more of that distance
and then kind of opening up again
camping at night and Joel being like oh
[__] what if there is people and like
being a little extra paranoid of like
standing out guard because if she was
just cargo he'd probably be like yeah
it's fine I'll just go to bed but
there's some tiny thing in his head
that's like ooh protector mode no I'm
gonna stay up with the gun
um
I really like that in the show that
whole camping scene in the shots of the
trees and her looking up and also him
lying to her I think he says something
like nobody's gonna come well like
there's no one no one knows what he is
and yeah clearly doesn't know like he's
that's something that you would only
really say to someone that you care
about to protect them from the knowledge
I think yeah there's a lot of nice
touches there Eddie you were gonna say
something and I think we interrupted you
[__] Eddie dude
but uh I actually don't remember what I
was gonna say sick
um but I can bring something up that
Jakey mentioned right before we hopped
in that I was very happy about because
Jakey and I had many many many phone
calls aside from our regular many phone
calls when he was making his last first
two video and my conference calls
straight up I was talking to you about
that Last of Us 2 video at create a
clash last year it was when you were
working on that I know that much
or it had just come out no maybe that
was the next one yeah that that was it
had been out at that point because it
was it's just you know it's just really
a timeline on all of our Lives when that
video came out yeah but I have said to
Jakey and Chrissy and a couple of people
around me for for years that I could
write a paper on how flawed of a
character Tommy is in a great and real
way and for years I feel like people
have glorified Tommy is Joel's brother
because they have a relationship but I
was like did you guys not notice that he
like abandons everything because he has
a hero complex and even in the game he
has a good setup with like a family or
like you know he's he's taking care of
people and then Joel comes with Ellie
and he's immediately like okay yeah no I
can do this and he's ready to book it
and leave everyone else and can I
mention last of us too is that cool for
people listening to okay yes everybody
yeah the last of us too he pretty much
toward the end goes to which is a sense
actually his his niece and is like hey I
know you're happy but I think for me you
need to go on this Revenge Mission and
abandon your child and it's like I have
always wanted me and hated him in the
same way vein and then Joel had that
conversation in the truck and I like
stood up I was like
Tommy's [__] up should we address that
tell me kind of stuff yeah because I
feel like there was so much of like I've
only seen Tommy spoken about in a
positive light and I like Tommy because
he's a complex character yeah but it's
like he
I don't know he just seems to be willing
to abandon anybody that he loves for
some kind of thing to save and then the
fact that they save you a complex Sarah
complex yeah he's a joiner right isn't
that what Joel says yeah yeah when that
scene played I was like on Eddie's
behalf because he had brought that up
and we talked about it and I was like
yeah because when I was writing that
video or whatever I was thinking about
so many things but somehow the Tommy
stuff just like wasn't at the Forefront
and it's like whoa as credit to Neil and
Haley and like you know anyone that
worked on the game like Tommy has way
more depth and I love that in the show
they were like they spell it out a
little more they're like no he's he's a
he's a joiner and he like I see him that
the added details of like you went to
the Army and then that wasn't it and
then he did this and then he'd win the
fireflies but he probably quit that and
uh yeah yeah no Eddie classic Eddie
moment
Tommy's VA was in the episode as well
which I didn't know which is really cool
that guy started talking and I turned a
billion I was like that sounds like
Tommy me like dumb ass in me forgot that
like no he's in the show and then was he
the one who was like talking to Kathleen
yeah he's all set up the whole episode
he had a beard and like graying hair and
you both went America
he had like the Arthur Morgan like hair
tonic look of like Max beard slipping
yeah oh yeah he looked awesome that's
cool I didn't realize he looks sick what
did you guys I don't know why I'm still
dancing around it because we've already
like like glossed over so many spoilers
but the the pit the shaking pit you
think that's like a bloater birthplace
that's what I'm assuming yeah yeah which
was a fun one to have us not no because
obviously like we didn't have the moment
in the school which I'm with you I think
like most people have this dance of like
that's really fun in a video game and
I'm very glad it was in the video game
and not on grounded mode that [__] sucks
but I'm glad it's there whereas I think
in a TV show that becomes a little bit
too cartoony and a little bit silly um
and I think if they use a bloated they
probably have to do it in a way that's
just really scary rather than super
actiony and I think leading into to the
idea of them being there in an ominous
way again I'm assuming that's a boiler I
can't imagine it being anything yeah it
seems like this it's cool it's fun it's
exciting they maybe they're changing it
where they're like born out the mud like
an urakai
I would also learn monster just taking a
fork I was looking for it to to be a
bloater but also my vote is to never see
a stalker ever in real life in this show
because they scare me
I don't want to see one of those
stalkers because I do but like uh that's
I I don't know if I'll be able to handle
that one I'm I'm not great with horror
but I will watch it I have to so there
were way more of them in part two right
like in part one aren't they only there
are they in part one I think they're
briefly there maybe not as they're like
I don't remember own official enemy type
I want to say there are some zombies no
they remember there's the part after or
when you're still with Sam and Henry
when you go through the tunnels and the
sewers they're in there the stalkers are
in that part of the first game you're
right but but yeah in part two there's a
[__] ton of them during Abby's and
Ellie's section I think where it's like
I remember there's one part I think with
Ellie right before it switches to Abby
or maybe after we're going through like
an old office building or something and
it's just all stalkers and like that
[__] they are terrifying I mean I I used
to when I first played The Last of Us
which is when it came out I used to have
to take breaks because it made me so
anxious that I was sick to my stomach
and playing it again through now I'm
like oh wow I've really hardened to
video games
yeah yeah I mean part two is just like
just the whole thing's so harrowing the
whole time I think going back it's
almost Pleasant you're like oh just on a
road trip this is cool and also it's
like a third of the length
25 hours or whatever
um so how did you guys feel about the
whole Kathleen thing and the um the
different perspective that we had there
because I wasn't expecting that to
happen when we went into this episode
because in the in the game it's kind of
just like a faceless enemy right like
Sam and Henry had some history with some
Raider group or something but it's just
like a faceless tank that's chasing you
right we get very little info on who
they are yeah I think in the show I'm
mad intrigued like I just really like
that actor and I think she's so good I
think she's she's yeah she's chilling
she's Yellow Jackets right yeah yeah I
thought she was brilliant like to the
conversation with the doctor I wasn't
entirely sure why I needed to know that
information of like why it was her
doctor I wasn't really sure but that
ending with her walking and being like
open the door and just like off camera
shooting him in the face because they
said they didn't need a doctor I was
like damn that's Savage like I guess
this is an Insight of like the personal
relationships of the world not mattering
so much in extreme circumstances and
like what this living in this or trying
to survive through this universe can do
to you mentally and like people you
don't think will turn on you will and I
imagine that's what that scene was an
expression yeah that's that's a good
point because I was a little lost in in
the sauce and that stuff too of like
specifically her I pieced together
obviously that it was like Sam and Henry
must have killed someone close to her
someone important to her in their
getting out of that group or something
she's really mad at me for some reason
right I could be wrong but I think they
suggested that Henry was a part of fedra
when her brother was killed by them
right oh see like I said I think so too
but I'm also not positive and I think
that conversation is to also
um like that specific conversation is to
also uh show how she personally knows
Henry and also
um what uh like what role he played in
her own you know like Revenge Mission
here
um so Chad is saying Henry sold a
brother out to fedra sold her brother
that's Federal okay so yeah I think yeah
I think that is what it just it felt
like it all happened really fast in that
first scene where she's talking with him
and like you know watching it with
someone else I didn't want to have to
like stop and Rewind it but I think more
so than any of the other episodes as
good as they were this one I felt the
most compelled to re-watch just because
it felt so just like there was a lot
even though it was one of the shorter
ones like for 45 minutes yeah yeah yeah
it's definitely yeah I mean I I think
actually we we did rewind some parts of
this one and I will say you know the
only thing I didn't like about this
episode
um was
I wish that I didn't know who Henry was
in pot because the end of this episode
is people that we know whereas so I know
it's okay right so like if you're a TV
audience you'd be like oh my God
Somebody's Knocking oh [__] and I feel
like I kind of lost that like that
ending like because I saw that I was
like I saw that Ellie was scared and I
was like oh my God is it Kathleen what's
happened and then it's them and I was
like oh well they'll be fine like I'm
glad they're in it obviously I love
those two characters but I was like kind
of a bummer like that's the thing that
the TV audience gets but I guess also
the use of the name like Henry
repeatedly like I almost wish in some of
these instances they'd changed a name
just so I didn't know that like that was
a good thing I'm excited to see him but
yeah like that was the only thing that
got me that I ended up being like Oh
well they're fine [__] up thing to be
sad about to be fair it's the gamer text
it's the price you pay for it it's true
gamers are oppressed you know what I'm
saying
uh I think especially after
um after episode three I I don't is
there
I'm just so emotionally scared for next
for Friday like I just don't I don't
want to do it it's too much I had asked
Troy
um
which of the next episodes is the
scariest because uh one of the other
guests that I'm having this podcasting
is Mike Flanagan who's a horror director
and I was like is there a particular
episode that you think I should ask Mike
to be on and he said episode five so I'm
assuming episode five is you have to be
actually scared and really emotional I
don't know if it's gonna be like super
super scary but I think like the tone of
it is probably gonna be a lot darker and
I actually think that's the thing that
episode four if you look at it from a
writing perspective is a lot of bridges
for other things like it's almost an
example of how to do Exposition at an
expert level they're giving us a ton of
context they're giving us more insight
into Joel and Ellie's relationship and
why they have to care about each other
they're giving us lore about all of the
humans in the world and how they operate
they're giving us a little bit of
insight into how fedra operates there's
a lot of like just stuff that happens in
this episode that pieces other things
together or sets other things up in a
way that nobody's ever looking at camera
and being like and now the two care
about each other it's just so like well
dripped to you that I was like I really
respect the amount of work this position
nice
yeah
I just feel like it definitely set up a
lot of stuff that
it's just like I'm just I'm very glad
that I don't feel like the internet is
gatekeeping The Last of Us which is kind
of shocking people aren't being like
well I played the game I haven't seen
any of that and I'm also not seeing
people spoil it for the TV audiences
which is super [__] nice because I
just can't wait to see how people react
to the end I'm like I'm so excited to
see the mass meltdown dude for real like
I I have friends in a group chat back in
New York that like they're like Gamers
but they're mostly playing like Call of
Duty and stuff like shout out to it
he's always texting me like this episode
was crazy blah blah and it's he was like
is this the same story as the game I'm
like broad Strokes yeah but there's some
stuff that's different and I'm like oh
you haven't played it have you like all
you [__] have no idea like I'm
jealous but I'm also like I don't know
I'm also kind of happy that I'm paying
the gamer text of like it's interesting
to see how they're changing too I think
as especially a live week by week TV
experience it's why I when I started
seeing the changes why I love them so
much is because like it does two things
like you mentioned that like it's kind
of you you don't know if you can spoil
it if you've played the game because
like you don't know exactly and like for
for the people watching who have played
the game like you uh you like don't know
what's next you don't know what to
expect sure and I think that's so cool
because I already would have loved to
watch a show that is just like one to
one of the last of us and done well but
now it's like this week I don't know
what they're gonna change I don't know
what's gonna be better like what's gonna
be uh like something could potentially
be worse in the future but like it's
it's such a um an active viewing
experience than just seeing it directly
made for TV they've done a really good
job of of rebalancing certain things so
that for us the cameos are exciting and
I keep saying it's really interesting to
watch the show do this well because you
know the moments that the Dora quotes
that we all find really cool aren't that
because of that they're not there so
that we'll be like oh they said the
thing it's there because it was just the
perfect thing to say yeah and so it's so
satisfying to be like this is like fan
service without you actually trying to
make ticket fan service like it's just
good and so we we get to just be like
yeah that was good at the time and it's
still really good now and it's nice that
none of that stuff feels cheap or at
least nothing I've seen I'm sure there
are like people on YouTube doing
breakthrough videos of like oh did you
see this reference to this thing that I
probably missed a million off but for
the most part none of it feels honest
there is just feels amazing there's one
of those that I think Billy and Eddie
had shown me because they're both on
Tick Tock like we were talking about
before I'm a YouTube shorts baby
comparatively but they showed that the
uh the shirt that Joel takes after they
take showers at Frank and Bill's is
Frank's shirt the green shirt that's
like the you know his iconic like from
the game I think too and I'm like damn
that it's such a small thing but that's
such a cool like even if somewhere in
Neil's mind or someone in the game that
that was the story of I mean I guess he
had the shirt before that I don't know
where I'm going with that but I I just
think stuff like that it's really cool
yeah I will say though that moment is a
missed opportunity in the show because
they didn't show us Joel in the shower
that's true
major Pascal they didn't have the like
[__] was it like heavy rain or some game
that had like a shower mini game
that you had to do by the way you could
not get in the shower oh Jason
isn't it like one of the it doesn't
matter to get into it but I'm pretty
sure it's one of the female characters
too that the game's just like by the
power of the PS3 you might be right all
I remember is being in the shower and
not being allowed to get out what what
great game David cage
he puts you in the cage I think it was
that also the was that like some kind of
controversy around in somebody breaking
the game was it was it maybe
it might have been yeah oh yeah maybe
which is such an interesting period of
time because wasn't that that was the
the same time the loss of us was about
to come out
to speak up about how much Ellie looks
like Elliott page yeah it was so wild
when they were like well I'm in this
game you caught what are you doing and
it I don't know if it was intentional or
not it's super interesting
um yeah
I also this episode uh I just felt like
I'm consistently Blown Away by the sets
and the environments there has not been
any moment ever where I've not fully
believed this nor even seen CG which is
so weird after watching every [__]
Star Wars Disney show and being like Oh
that's a fake background like the budget
for this show is just so clear and has
been used so so so well like I loved
seeing the city uh yeah especially that
last episode I was just like
power of
amazing a joke that Eddie said this is
stupid I was about to say the power of
the series s but wow
I was over at Eddie's and know I was
watching him play seafood and I just
started doing like karate moves in front
of him and he was like powered by series
I thought it was really my favorite
games yeah
you play it I just watched Eddie play it
and I'm like wow this is so good dude I
haven't beaten it yet I mean what are
you up to this is a separate podcast but
I uh I uh the club I beat and then um
did you beat it without dying
um I've beaten so I beat the the first
area at 20 and I think I beat the club
at 22 so not yet but I've been doing
that in sushimon Lethal mode back and
forth for a bit I don't know why all
right yeah it's been fun very cool okay
well when you get to the um the boss at
the end of level three of sifu where I
was like oh
oh I see what this game is you see so
rough nice that's how I felt about the
club boss so I'm just excited no you'll
get to a point when you find the club
bus really easy you're like this [__]
guy whatever who cares Dodge whatever
and then and then things get bad in any
case The Last of Us
um I did want to ask you both Before I
Let You Go how you felt about the test
kiss because I feel like that's a thing
a lot of people have a lot of opinions
on was there any anything you felt about
the obviously end of episode two
I might let Eddie take this one but yeah
it's like one of probably the only
things in the show that's made me at
least go like hmm me too yeah it was um
because we watched that one uh together
we held hands for that yeah it was uh it
was one where right before actually
coming in we were talking about what we
liked about the changes and I forgot to
mention in the beginning because I think
I might have said that I like every
change but right before we came in I
said I like every change except for the
test kiss because like I get I get the
explanation I get what they're trying to
do I did not like how the moment was
like directed I just it it just felt it
felt weird there was just like a weird
undertale I think that um because I keep
thinking about this and talking to
people about the kiss
I think Direction may have been a big
part of the issue there because part of
it is that you don't know how Tess is
feeling
and and that that's like it's very hard
to sell that when she's got something on
her face and like she's trying to look
at white but because of her like lack of
movement you don't know what you're
supposed to be taking from her in that
moment is she afraid that's really good
not afraid because she's too far through
the Turning I would have said that like
if I were to reckon that and what the
[__] do I know John trapping knows what
he's doing he's fine but I think I would
have been like desperation probably you
were desperate to get this to work to
make it mean something to save them and
I don't feel like we saw that on her
face so I I feel like the pro it would
have been a little bit more succinct if
we'd like very much felt what Tess was
feeling at the time and I think that
obviously very hard to do but maybe that
was like kind of part of the problem is
we're not sold on how she felt so we
don't really know what to take away from
it as much was part of it supposed to be
the actual like biological draw of being
a infected
that's what I assume too that there had
to have been something I would I don't
even know if it's like an audio cue or
visual or yeah the fact that maybe if
she like like stepped forward more it's
yeah it was one of those things where I
think especially right before the
episode ended everyone in the room when
we saw that bit was just kind of like oh
yeah yeah I think hold on I think you
kind of just nailed on that I didn't
even realize what it was I didn't like
about it I think that's exactly it but I
think that it it
I I thought about it a lot and I think
that I would have been more sold on it
whether it's like a biological thing of
like oh she's like getting infected and
so she's not resisting this as much but
the fact that she's still trying to
light the lighter and that it was I
don't know maybe you're supposed to
interpret her kind of just vacant gays
whatever as like she's just going numb
of like I don't know whether to Panic or
whether to do this whatever but if I
don't know whatever I think whatever the
intention was it didn't quite fully land
yes there are a lot of people who do
like it and you know it could totally be
our preference but I I feel like when it
comes to how a character is feeling at a
certain point in time
the direction of that should be
consistent we can take different
meanings away from like you know Ellie
cutting the face open we can take a
different meaning away from that
um but when it comes to like something
as Extreme as how they die I feel like
it should be very clear and kind of not
open to interpretation and that's why
some of us are like I don't know how to
take this because I don't know how she
took it but like in my head it was that
she was succumbing to it because she was
already being infected anyway
um and part of the way that cordyceps
works is like when they take over the
body of an insect they will force it to
fly to a warm place so that then they
can actually breed properly like that's
a thing that it actually does it like
takes over the body makes it go
somewhere warmer and then basically like
expands so that it can spread to other
things and it's like it makes sense if
she were
her body was being overtaken but her
mind was slowly going we just didn't
like see that too strongly yeah yeah I
mean as as credit to it it definitely
the fact that we're even like talking
about it and that there is there is room
for these different takes is so much
better than it's like it's not even like
a flaw maybe like a small like I said
like a huh thing but it's not even like
another show where it's just blatantly
like why the [__] did you do that it was
more so just like oh I'm gonna have to
I'm gonna have to pray on that one yeah
you know it's totally more interesting
to have it be that way yeah also one
small unrelated thing if I can mention
really quick that I loved especially
about like little details of how this
show is directed
um I don't know if you guys felt the
same way or had the same kind of moment
in your brain but when they could go up
the stairs in this last episode
um they're like viewed down from like a
dark hallway and they use an office
plant in in like the foreground in the
dark and it looks almost identical to
fungus growing up the wall and it makes
you think for a moment if you notice
that that room is full of infected and
then it's just not it's just a regular
plant
um and I just thought like little bits
like that to make you just feel like the
characters are not safe when they're out
and Yeah like not you know like enclosed
in the qz or something the symbolism in
the show is amazing like top to bottom
like I keep talking about the uh I don't
know what happens before anymore now but
I think it's the scene where Joel beats
the [__] out of the guy and then it's a
hard cut to Ellie sitting by herself
with the ray of light and I keep taking
that to be like and he is our savior or
someone I don't remember what this
before was exactly anymore but I know
whatever it was it's like a very
different tone that's like here's the
world that we're in here's the thing
that's going to save us literally beam
of sunshine child sitting cross-legged
and like there's so much of that like
lovely symbolism that I I honestly
already can't wait to watch this show
through a second time oh 100 so I take
off them like what's gonna happen hat
and be like how do they do that like
yeah just just give it the freaking
Better Call Saul treatment where it's
just like I'm just gonna keep
re-watching this and picking up I think
uh just to go back real quick to Ellie
being like more harsh and violent I
think that
um that it's the more I'm thinking about
the more it is pretty clear that like oh
yeah that is what they're doing because
even after she shoots the guy and Joel's
like you need to go in the other room
which again felt so real in her being in
there but when she's in there I mean she
like maybe cries for like a second and
then wipes them away and immediately
goes out there and it's not like
cracking jokes but it's just like oh
yeah no it's fine let's do this that
it's like I think that I'm thinking more
that it wasn't just someone coping for
the moment but it's like oh no this is
going to be them coping for their whole
life of just like oh yeah violence is
just a thing that happens I'll stab this
dude in the head I'll do this I'll do
this which like the fact that they
learned in school how to yeah yeah
that's pretty I think that was really
well done of just like no this is the
sad reality and I think like Eddie said
of changing Joel's reaction to being
like I just don't think that kids should
have to do this I think that's very
intentional like no but a kid doesn't
have to do this and we're gonna see the
effects of it in part two
I also think um Joel's little
conversation with um with Ellie and the
show about uh her generation is like a
first I think really good kind of uh
like worked in and not too obvious like
coveted parallel for teens watching the
show
um I thought that was really cool and I
just I like especially bringing in stuff
like that from real life that is not uh
you know like way too on the nose like a
like a sitcom on Zoom or whatever the
hell they did yeah I mean it definitely
went over my head but now you're saying
that I'm like yeah it is interesting
that this show was in development for
like 10 years like getting have been
shopped around a million times I mean
like they had had an interest in making
it for that long and it only came
together because I'm pretty sure after
Chernobyl Craig had a conversation with
HBO where he was like I want to make the
last of us and then they just made it
happen but it was something that I think
that like they had wanted to do for a
really long time I could be completely
incorrect about I don't even remember
who told me this I could be way wrong uh
but the fact that it happened maybe I am
yeah maybe I dripped it
um but the fact that it happened after
covet I feel like does make it hit
different because it could have happened
before and I felt the same way obviously
playing through part two during covid I
was [__] alone in a studio apartment
they're like oh God what a dark time
what's happening okay Troy told them put
that story on the last podcast so
apparently that's from Troy Baker and I
didn't make it up great news for me
everybody redeemed
next time I'm gonna lie I'm just gonna
completely make that up but like I feel
like it yeah the fact that it's it's
post covered makes us all look at this
with a really really different lens and
um yeah I'm like I should be
appreciative of it or not Craig and Neil
Mike
tests the thing that gets in her mouth
you know they're just like they're
they're such a good team which one has
the lighter
I don't know neither it's fine yeah
they're doing a great job and I think
that like they've just worked with a lot
of really good people like I Believe
episode three
um they intentionally worked with a lot
of gay dudes as well which is like a
thing that they didn't need to do but
I'm I'm pretty sure the director is a
gay man like a thing that
you know a million other shows wouldn't
have done and why not take that
opportunity to have
a gay content creator or content creator
is not the right word for that industry
but who cares we're claiming it back
everybody
it's Joey Graceffa
uh I just feel like that's like a really
awesome choice and a great thing to do
and not that it didn't seem authentic
anyway but to tap into that it just
feels like top to bottom it's being made
with so much love and care for real yeah
I don't know why because you mentioned
that I just thought of the post episode
like interview and they show the
director and you just see the lower
thirds just say gay Viner
[Laughter]
the other K is redundant uh how did you
guys feel about
um
uh completely forgotten what I was gonna
ask Halo the Halo TV show I didn't even
watch it okay I'm only asking because I
think I met you both through playing
Halo uh because it's just so nice to
watch a video game show after Halo which
I thought was absolutely awful and just
have it be good and have everybody think
it's good like it's just so [__] nice
like it's just such a treat and I also
love that we're getting these weekly
releases so we can have these
conversations it's such a fun part of it
and like you said I think Jakey that
things are close to the same but not
identical so it's still fun for us
um and like I do think you're probably
right Eddie that we know what's
happening next episode for the most part
but we don't know how it's gonna happen
yeah
they're definitely having their cake and
eating it too of like we know a large
audience tuning in is gonna have played
the game but like because the show is
doing so well the mass majority of
people probably haven't played the game
but the fact that like we're all into it
and excited and like such a win yeah so
close we're gonna get so many people
into gaming when a hit like this is also
a you know an adaptation of a video game
like you know we already saw the part
one sales went like crazy yeah
um I just think a lot of people will be
buying ps5s and having their first
gaming experiences and that's awesome
hey means a lot keep it up buy a
PlayStation 5 today God of War Ragnarok
available in stores now
I was playing it earlier today thanks we
appreciate that
PlayStation show it's super cool it's
for the the whole like PlayStation
accessibility oh that's like a big team
yeah it's pretty dope it's just saying
do you have do you have more of those
shirts for me and Eddie I could get them
but they are employee only but I think I
could get them sign me up I was gonna
say I can't I would actually I'd wear
this [__] out it is a bit but now I'm
like
probably yeah let's discuss that after
the show
um okay do you think we'll see more of
Kathleen and and what role do you think
she has to play I anticipate she will at
least be in I mean the next episode but
a selfishly kind of hoping after that I
mean I know they only have what Nine
episodes to tell the story of the whole
game but like I hope that she's around
at least for a bit and I have a feeling
they will I don't think that they would
just like you know have her and then
dump her but I mean I don't know even if
she was only just in the next episode
and it was more of a One-Shot thing kind
of like Mick Offerman and
I'd be into that but yeah I I think I
think she's gonna be around for at least
a bit I think they're building her up
the chat thinks she's gonna get killed
by a bloater
they're probably oh dude what if they
had the animation from like when you die
as Joel and the bloater like
that'd be crazy right before Super Bowl
Sunday and everyone he's like oh
smart of them to push it up to Friday
because I was like oh it's sooner and
like not having been paying attention to
football I totally forgot about the
Super Bowl dude even in the Super Bowl I
[Music]
even not being a huge football fan like
I always liked watching the Super Bowl
because it's kind of just a holiday
where it's an excuse to just like
everybody's watching it yeah
yeah well um I was gonna say let you
know why don't we uh have a nice Super
Bowl party but then that's also just
another conversation we're really just
planning other things live on the
internet sorry there are addresses
online
twitch chat all right we'll see you then
um any closing thoughts anything anybody
else feels like my other question was
going to be rank the episodes but I feel
like that's hard
uh they they're all really good I would
say
s tier episode three yeah a like if
we're doing this like smash character
style it would be like how else would
you do it yeah all of them or I don't
know some some have like a double A or S
I don't know I would just say three
slightly edges the rest of them but the
uh the rest of them are all pretty close
but I would I would maybe put this last
one right below three I really liked
this last one interesting I keep
thinking about it and it really stuck me
even though like you said it's just a
Bridge to Terabithia
that's the quote Yeah there's so many
just little moments in it like I said I
think it's the first one where I'm like
damn I want to watch it a second time
totally yeah how about you Eddie if I'm
going in order I think three is at the
top then
one then four and then two but I don't
dislike two I thought it was great but I
think that's the I think I agree even
though when I just finished watching two
I was like I that one was my favorite
and now when I'm thinking about it it
feels different like I reflecting on it
well that's just because it's so good
like that's that's all so good yeah very
excited to see more
um someone in chat said who's this guy
on the top left yikes nice nice very
good nice
Eddie I love that you put your your
YouTube button on a couch like it has a
it has a nice little seat to watch you
make it's sentient it's very cute that I
unpacked it and then um I haven't moved
it since but then I'm like I need the it
looks like I'm trying to be like C
I have this clock that that's a picture
of me but the other side is the clock
and I wish they could have flipped it
because otherwise it looks like I have a
picture of myself on my wall and because
the bookcase runs it off just that
that's me it's not my favorite what is
the the big Elden ring things they're
like an Elden ring skateboard deck what
what is it'd be cool though um it was
they sent it to the guy who who like
helped the thousand people beat Melania
it was let me solo her yes like a pretty
limited box that is now empty because
I've hung everything in it that had
Elden ring sword it came with a cape uh
this like wood-cut art of Melania a map
and a letter
um and I've I hung all of them uh this
weekend yeah it looks so so cool I don't
want to get rid of the box it's like
very broken from shipping and it looks
really cool on stream I kind of like it
being there too but I'm going to
probably post a picture of her the sword
is I mounted the sword above my TV and
it looks [__] awesome because it's
really big too yeah it's so cool in any
case everybody thank you for chatting to
me about The Last of Us episode for
Eddie where can people find you is there
anything you're working on right now
um I'm working on a YouTube video
that'll probably come out in five years
uh you can find me any it's just my name
everywhere it's Eddie with a Y oh my my
lighting like went down
also how do people do people spell Eddie
other than with a Y often an ie they
sure do is it real in my my life's
battle is saying with a wine well
imagine calling yourself Char Al on his
eye
people like how do I spell it and I go
don't worry about it you can find me
good luck it's fine Eddie with a Y is
much easier yeah that's true uh Nicky
Jakey where where are you on the
internet and are you working on anything
what you just said and I was gonna
piggyback off that of like uh the
specifically the Nike Jake is that at
least for music and stuff it's just
Jakey or like on social media a lot of
places it's just Jakey but whenever it's
like friends of family or older people
when I say like oh I make YouTube videos
essays and they're like that's really
interesting what is it and I'm like uh
they're like they have no context
they're like what are you doing on
YouTube are you allowed to do that on
YouTube
it's my name in the middle of Charizard
but then my name Alana is a weird name
to spell because it has so many
spellings anyway yeah again if you find
me I'm happy for you if not that's also
great don't worry about it it's fun yeah
yeah
um just Jakey Nicky Jakey everywhere
working on videos that's about it we had
a lot of people in chat that I I saw
today mention the music and how much
they've been enjoying the album
congratulations on that it's very good
stuff appreciate it so much
do you want me to do that um it's I
don't have a it's only a PlayStation
logo but I was gonna do my second plug
of the show but I don't have a stream
rom-com show devastatingly uh but you
could soon because maybe someone's
making merch oh [__]
thank you you are
you all no I I it's just I can't I can't
say I can't say when or where but it's
it's happening yeah well well stay tuned
uh thank you both for joining me
thanks for having me thank you everybody
for watching I am going to start
streaming more of part one as soon as I
end this part of the stream but I'm
going to stop the stream and then start
it again so if you want to see me play
more in part one then stay in the chat
but I'm gonna have to end the stream
anyway so I'll see you all next time bye
bye
[Music]